no that's not your speakers playing up
this does not sound like a v8 Corvette
that's because it isn't not anymore
the 2006 zo6 has been converted to an
all electric drivetrain back in February
the modifiers of this machine generation
set the land speed record for an
all-electric street-legal vehicle one
hundred and eighty six point eight miles
per hour but they weren't satisfied they
wanted to go faster so they made some
improvements to their car it's far from
silent the twin electric motors and the
tiny waves make it sound almost rocket
propelled as it uses all of the
available 600 horsepower and 570
foot-pounds of torque
yep that is a space shuttle in the
background the generation g XE has been
running high-speed laps around the old
shuttle landing runway Kennedy Space
Center it's the perfect place for driver
Johnny boomer to push the car to the
limit
the official monitoring showed he
actually achieved 205 point 6 miles an
hour a new world record generation plans
to start selling modified Corvettes to
anyone with north of around 330 thousand
dollars to spend you could buy three
Tesla's with that but they don't come
with not one but two will record